alright Erin Sampson we didn't bring
your beautiful face on this couch just a
talk about 83 a battlefield hardline and
so this is this was a noun it was a nice
about a month before e3 sort of leet
little leaky on battlelog yeah for sure
you are you you were one of the experts
on battlefield you're probably the
person who plays battlefield more than
anyone in the office in your home time I
feel at White at the gate what are your
impressions of hardline so visceral made
air is making battlefield hardline
instead of diced this year they sort of
handed it off visceral made I believe
his end game dlc for Battlefield 3 all
right did they okay yeah idea that was
just recently announced these guys are
taking their best crack at their sort of
crime drama battlefield game it's really
interesting like I'm having a good time
I enjoy heist mode a lot I'm also
enjoying blood money it does so the
question the big question right now is
how does this game feel two players yeah
so right now I think visceral has a bit
of an uphill battle because it feels
like a mod or it feels like a piece of
DLC I agree and so they're really gonna
have to bring a lot more to the table to
just convince battlefield players that
they're not just playing sixty dollars
just paying sixty dollars for a slightly
iterative experience I guess that's
where maybe the single-player stuff
comes into the fold but the beta is that
right now I want you to jump in okay at
right now run it we're gonna ask you a
bunch of questions and a focus at home
have any questions at all for iron and
Chris as well feel free to send them and
use the usual we've actually got the new
gamespot chat up which we had over at e3
any folks who have been freely word for
/ chat on giant bomb will know how it
works so if you have any questions do
ask Daniel Dwyer or not or feel free to
just stick them at gamespot on Twitter
or in the twitch chat and that the folks
in the back wall will get them into me
here first of all while I aren't setting
up Chris waters if you play much of this
yet I've played a bit yeah I played a
bit on PC and on PlayStation 4 of course
they announced thing during the end of
the e a press conference kicking it off
yeah and we'll still haven't like wait a
week to play it oh yeah of course I beta
is out on pc xbox one on six words
ah I'm not sure but yeah so I've got
it's a good time with it on different
consoles definitely you know Aaron Aaron
sort of cut to the quick there with the
does it feel like a mod doesn't feel and
I mean it certainly in the beta form
it's of course going to because it's
only a small multiplayer bit there's
only two modes one map and it's you know
it feels like something it's running on
frostbite 3 it's that you're the
animations all that stuff is very
battlefield yeah like the UI is is
basically what about it looks like like
colors and teams and stuff yeah but you
can sort of get this glimpse of how
they're trying to differentiate within
the loadout screens within the
progression screens are definitely
trying to create a different visual look
in those damn it nicely done that is
some pretty great defense that you'll
park the car on top of the helicopter
before kids take off move that's pretty
good effort before people ask aren't
playing this on PC and getting voided
and doing the soap he's got a self
revive okay as part of his kit which is
really interesting and I really I
remember at this having this ability and
killzone 2 multiplayer and oh no it's
something that like a lot of people can
use in this game you're just like
hardwired to think dead is dead it's
multiplayer shooter so so many times you
use the self revive and just get up and
no one's looking at you you can just
could just murder everybody other times
you blow up it but you know I earn first
of all when I asked you at the vehicles
in this game they feel a lot difference
to what the vehicles are used for at
least about film yes what's your take on
in battlefield 4 any time you had a
vehicle that was a non armored vehicle
like an MRAP hmm get a pebble the thing
would just explore yeah I mean they were
really really underpowered so I think
visceral has done a good job in this
game of making cars more useful and the
purpose of that is so you can get into
things like car chases you know cars
handle better they take more damage they
can bounce off objects sometimes a
little comically yeah in the case of the
motorcycle you ride that thing along
walls oh yeah you like hit a jaw it'll
it and it's it what's interesting it
doesn't just like fly up next to the
wall it kind of looks like the tires
like adhere to the wall a little bit
is it tilt it's definitely a matrix
style like wall yeah it's great but you
know again I'm okay with these things as
long as there's purpose behind them and
again the purpose is to keep players in
in the battle longer you know you don't
want us to be riding down the street in
the vehicle and get hit by three bullets
your vehicle explodes and then there's
no car chases because vehicles are too
fragile so you know visceral said that
was one of the ways they differentiated
this game that's true whether you know
they need to talk about more things now
that mmm they need to talk about they
brought they brought some gadgets that
are new semi-new like the zip line sort
of a throwback to battlefield 2 yeah our
force are people using those so the zip
lines actually really cool to get home
rooftop to rooftop is that's more
secrets i preserved yeah oh well other
players can use it for example when you
have get money and blood money you run
down the middle of the street you're
just going to run over by somebody so
you can use a zip line so you know
bridge the gap between two areas or get
down the street a lot faster now the
grappling hook hold on before we move on
from zip one I just want to confess I
was playing a match before we came on
the show yeah straight up shot to death
by zip line oh wait here I shot the same
idea dude killed me with the zip line
how who were this like he's on top of
the garage and I'm kind of here I was
like my weapon wasn't too long range so
he lined it up but all of a sudden it
just died SI getting killed by a smoke
grenade in counter-strike this cable is
coming out of my killcam brain and it
says kill by zip line there's a lot of
talent too because the zip lines don't
just go anywhere they only attached to
certain objects boys
rocket launcher all right what are you
doing why are you shooting that thing
revolution baby so you you probably
you're on the team that's cracking do
you want to take this crane down because
it blocks vehicle traffic okay that the
team that's trying to prevent you from
doing that you know they need to use
this route this is heist mode in which
it's actually lopsided goals hmm so it's
more akin to rush as opposed to blood
money mode which is just everyone
grabbing money from football and yeah
well yeah what do you think about the
modes aren't obviously like you pay a
lot of outfield do you think this that's
the sort of thing that you need to do to
reengage people or to make it
interesting if they're going to try to
realize this thing I mean I would like
to see them come up with some completely
unique modes blood money is pretty good
because it's this case of focus ok blood
money is a it's a case of a mood where
you do have some new dynamics like
everybody's rating the center money pile
but then everybody's also going on
rating each other's money pile yeah so
that does so genuinely new high smooth
feels like a game of Russia blitar ation
it's not super unique but it is still
fun as long as both teams know what
they're doing yeah that's the one thing
i found that maybe on the ps4 there's
much less of is that the pc folks seem
to kind of be working together a little
better yeah just gonna stand here you
think that's just right down to the sort
of the playerbase yeah i mean i guess i
would make that generalization about
most competitive shooters i think if you
want a pc that has that can run this
game pretty well then you're probably is
your first person shooters a lot i'm
gonna type in to the user questions man
also wanna let people know that we are
giving away 20 beta codes for
battlefield hardline on the ps4 today
whoo the game spot account has just
tweeted something I believe in the past
couple of minutes so if you want to win
and one of those beta codes all you have
to do is retweet that and make sure
you're following gamespot so we can get
your details and get that coat over to
you as well this is North America only
apologies that's that's not up to us we
got 20 code so if you want to get in on
that retweet that bad boy I'll bottom
fast to debate only
two more days oh yeah you're right it's
have you done yeah get the code watch
other starter guide that Aaron and I put
together are you all right sweet it's
like bike park or if I didn't that in
battlefield 4 I would die if I love dasa
asks in the chest d do the classes
represent the cops vs Roberts motif or
are there thief engineers and police is
sold i was on stuff working there just
renamed battlefield for me classic sizes
are the same regardless of what faction
you play as and they all at least in the
beta at this point the thing that
differentiates them i mean you have this
sort of the gun ranges right the SMGs
the machine guns the assault rifles the
sniper rifles yeah jet like generally
speaking then you've got the bits of kit
that you can get so like the ballistics
you've got a riot shield in one class
you've got the revived teammates and
revive yourself in another class Aaron
you and have done some messing around
with the riot shield not not not super
nice full yet it needs to stop more
bullish before I'd use it but what one
thing so one big addition that hard line
does which i think is worth mentioning
is it more or less gets rid of that kind
of slog of an unlock tree that was in
battlefield yes so it's got the i don't
we're just calling it the coin op system
but it's basically you pay money for the
weapons instead of having to unlock them
through levels although you still you do
still have to go through service stars
in order to get the ability to buy
certain attachments like barrel mods and
scopes and things like that but for the
most part you're kind of able to just
pick and choose what you want right
instead of you just unlock this new
version of this pistols you never use
anyway yeah so veteran battlefield
players know exactly which guns and
no which scopes they like and there's no
reason for them to be wasting their time
unlocking the red dot sight for the
hundredth time in a row it's just not
necessary and I think they listened and
that was I was really you know it's
really nice of them to do I think it's
something that the community wanted oh
yeah you're not spending your time with
some gun you don't want kidding it out
only to unlock the basic version of
another gun that you then have to kid
out then you know that's a sort of
cascade along that's always it's nice to
see that getting restructure are we any
guys talking to the chops of visceral
because I know that there's been a lot
of talk about it's not all just going to
be maps in cities like they definitely
showed a desert maps okay in the trailer
guys are cops yezzir to bank robbery
that was where you had the like real
vehicle heavy during that during the
demo trailer that was where it showed a
lot of like vehicle heavy cart racing
stuff basically through like a you know
trevor in GTA meth country rise what it
seemed like right so if you're gonna
have a vehicle based mode you know keep
having an urban area is pretty tricky
yeah so do you think that these wet
these vehicles then do have the ability
to actually make interesting vehicle
chases because one of the things are and
you said immediately when that first
trailer was released was that if they
use the battlefield 4 style vehicles
like all that ever happened was people
got rocket launchers and just blew them
up straight away like there was not much
in the way of compelling chasing ya
think you gotta you've got to
recalibrate right because the you know
the majority of the the vehicles in a
mainline battlefield our military spec
their tanks there's armored this there's
armored that but here you know when you
hit you can't you can have an armored
SUV yes on the criminal side but it's
mostly gonna be you know scars that you
can just comment here cut like yeah now
you sort of have to rescale the damage
modeling for vehicles and it seems like
Aaron's mentioned earlier that they've
kind of done that a little bit at least
in the beta though they are gonna have
to drive car chases a little bit more so
again going back to high smooth it's
really good when everybody knows what
they're supposed to do and where they're
supposed to go um but in earlier matches
when people don't really know that
you know the team that grabs the bomb
and they know where they're headed they
just go there nobody can really catch up
to them so they probably need to work
iced a little bit better so that I don't
know whether that means just more cars
or whether that means more indicators do
you think it's a matter of confusion or
snuffing able to get there in a timely
fashion or it could be you know it could
be like in rush where they move the
spawn point of the defenders after the
first set of crates are taken oh yeah
they should definitely something to
signal that yeah they need to rebalance
it a little bit just so you know
encourage those car chases so it looks
like my team's gone up they've gone up
and they're gonna try and zip line
across to the escape so well you're on
your own bra we'll go meet them over
there um but the potential for the car
chases is there they just need to maybe
maybe maybe playboy just get one like it
get back into the Calvin area so aren't
you you play a lot of battlefields
there's no doubt you're gonna pick this
up I'm guessing and somebody who spends
a lot of time with the series after
folks who were maybe Fairweather
battlefield fans who pick one up or
maybe have been trying to get into it so
far from the beta you think that there's
enough happening here to make it an
interesting new prospect for somebody
who may be played a bit about feel for
but was a little unsatisfied but I mean
if you're looking for a different
experience that's what this is if you
feel like the Battlefield franchise the
core Battlefield franchise has just
gotten a little tired then you know I I
think you can make the argument that
playing it a slightly simplified you
know differently seemed data field might
be the thing that you want to do does
this feel simplify to it does which is a
good thing I think battlefield 4 sort of
branched out a little bit too much you
know there were so many weapons in so
many mods that it kind of got
overwhelming for a lot of players
where's like I get shot from
this is one thing I like whenever you're
carrying money it's just streaming out
of the bag leaving this crazy money
trail oh okay that's your friend oh yeah
it's fun I'll get on my way oh you can
do it do it is nice what an iron wins
the game ah nice work Aaron one last I
feel it to your question Danny about
like is this different enough yeah like
if you want something different and the
criminal thing appeals to you payday 2
you think like it's very different in
the the mechanics of that in terms of
you know because you're fighting enemy
AI not you not other players it can feel
a little bit II like horde Modi where
you're just like fighting waves and
waves of cops but I think the strategy
of pulling off a crime and that kind of
tension is captured really well in
payday despite some some you know rough
edges 22 coming out on the next gen
consoles or the current-gen consoles
rather in a couple of months as well I
mean in payday 2 was done by an ex
battlefield dev so if it feels he's
mildly familiar I mean the mechanics are
very different it's more like a horde
mode that game is a lot of fun though
the big the real question that
everybody's asking themselves at this
point is this worth sixty dollars yeah
that's that's the actual question you
know this for forty dollars maybe there
would be no question in people's minds
even if it felt like a mod or felt like
DLC so you know the it's up to visceral
to make the case that this is a
sixty-dollar game and that's hard to do
when you've only shown one map in two
modes yeah so we'll see what they do do
you think they'll lean on the
single-player stuff though do you think
they'll say this is the single player
campaign you guys wanted and here's the
the multiplayer stuff to the side like
that's what I worried that they'll they
have a pretty padded obvious multiplayer
component and then they'll say oh but we
gave you this five hour campaign that no
one's go play or like I mean we have two
people gonna play we had an interesting
conversation in the office earlier today
where you know somebody mentioned that
the thing that used to make make a game
not a modern not dlc was a single player
campaign yeah but I don't feel like
battlefield people play battlefield for
single player you know maybe it's eight
hours out of your hundred two hundred
hours that you play so I think that you
know marketing thinks that yeah single
player is the thing that attracts people
I think battlefield players just want
solid multiplayer that's where they want
the money put and you know that's what
the experience that they want